so after pretending for weeks and weeks  that he wanted to debate his opponent  Senator wanna  I'm ready to debate Herschel Walker has  now turned down a debate with his  opponent Rafael Warnock I argue it  doesn't even matter his followers don't  care he can just tell his followers  Raphael Warnock won't debate me and his  followers will believe it because  they're the same people that were  swindled by Trump it's almost like they  want to fall for it  um he's not going to debate I've been  saying it for a very long time he has no  interest in debating and he shouldn't he  can barely speak  you know and uh you know that's the  problem that we have